[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais mir qui s'est massé moi je ne
connais pas rocco siffredi c'était celui
de le voir encoder mois vaillant cryptée
en clair se reconnaît pas à encoder
alors rocco siffredi donc vous jouer
dans un film de catherine breillat qui
sort le 14 avril qui s'appelle romance
avec caroline ducey sagamore stévenin et
françois berléand alors on en parle
beaucoup il ya un gros buzz comme on dit
chez les jeunes
c'est le premier film qui transgresse
les barrières entre le film x de films
pornos et le film d'auteur voilà alors
on va en parler tout à l'heure pendant
l'émission on va on va y revenir
notamment avec jeanne labrune
mais on va commencer par parler de vous
d'abord puisque c'est effectivement un
événement que vous soyez dans un film
d'auteur et de longueur et de largeur
longueur largeur effectivement fait
conséquences
alors vous êtes bon vous êtes la plus
grande j'ai pas la plus grosse parce que
mais la plus grande en tous les cas ces
stars me prends ça comme en avait
la jalousie je n'ai pas ma mairie comme
éviter la vulgarité
juste avant dix ans il est jaloux 8 cm
en érection
c'est pas la sienne micro pénis c'est
quoi un micro pénis
on dit que c'est de fait de moins de 8
cm du technicien
il fallait tout c'est pour ça que toutes
nos femmes qu'elle s'égare altaf devant
derrière puisque on leur fait croire
tout le temps que ça ça fait vingt
centimes
[Applaudissements]
on ira au bout de la terre de liberté ou
alors j'adore et léo d'ouvriers vous
vous êtes là c'est qu'il est vachement
éloigné d'un conte perte de temps non
plus à autun vous êtes le alain delon du
hard est d'ailleurs votre nom rocco
siffredi vient de roch siffredi qui est
vous le savez bien vous laurent guerry
soltane un cinéphile roch siffredi c'est
le nom réunion bravo oui bien il connaît
une chance pour ne voulait pas disney
800 films
vous avez pratiqué 3500 fille jeudi
pratiquer comme ça et alors vous avez
une spécialité mais une particularité
c'est que vous allez vous attendre mon
érection à peu près tout le temps qu'on
fasse des traits plus jeunes sur 10 ans
mais c'est bien quand j'étais plus jeune
ça me fait beaucoup mieux dans le sens
que c'est pour ça c'était mon défaut qui
a été un grand un gant comment dirais-je
davantage le négatif j'ai trop cool son
jeu les où l'on parlait à wil on va
parler de votre enfance parce que ça ça
commence très fort vers 7-8 ans d alors
bon pour finir pour finir sur votre pour
tenir sur les célébrités votre chèque ça
a été moulé et de nombreuses femmes
nombreux hommes l'ont acheté maintenant
il ya aussi une poupée gonflable de vous
qui existe s'est passé pas très bon ça
parce qu'ils m'avaient ma femme
effectivement mais dévoile avec toutes
les équipes
ça peut le dire tant qu les maintenant
au tour à quelqu'un qui va pouvoir tant
que lorsque j'avais ma place c'est très
bien
alors on va regarder un petit peu votre
votre vie votre story comme à ses plus
jeunes ne faut quand même dire que si on
considérait 10 est là c'est parce que
c'est le petit ami la productrice
catherine barma qui me l'a imposé
alors commencez pas à faire la fine
bouche chantier mademoiselle joue dans
une pièce de molière extérieur je
comprends que tout ça mais voyait dur de
mars
molière dur demain bien
record vous êtes les orteils donc est
une station balnéaire des abruzzes et
jusqu'à 7 8 ans vous avez eu donc une
enfance à peu près normale et à partir
de 7-8 ans vous avez eu des coups de
chaleur
on peut appeler ça comme ça mais des
coups de chaleur qui vous donner une
envie folle de venu de vous masturber et
qu'il a exactement ça et qui était dû à
votre métabolisme en fait c'est ça oui
je sais pas qu'est ce que c'était mais
j'arrivais parfois me masturber au moins
pendant dix faut dix fois par jour mais
parce que dès que je finissais jeu dès
que j'aurai l'orgasme ça a commencé à
l'intérieur c'était terrible parce que à
cet allègement déjà des gens retournent
assez pingre en huile on n'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir beaucoup disent
qu'ils ont du mal à longvic et la
disposition pour poids face aux besoins
de trouver une partenaire en plus comme
un bourbier
je me suis je me suis mince cube et
jusqu'à la dois je me masturbe encore
aujourd'hui et je pars en tôle et bien
mais je devais me c'est une boule
masturbation qui m'ont besbes de toute
façon n'aurait et moi je suis vachement
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
donc ça me pompe l'air dans votre
famille la femme des antécédents c'est
un petit peu at la victoire est ce que
votre père et c'est bon on cunnilingus
votre père était celle d'un guide se
veut bien je pense à calais 2
[Applaudissements]
dans les particuliers dans des tâches
qu'on n'est pas les histoires de ma
famille je sais que mon grand père ça
m'a fait beaucoup de monde cette
histoire parce que c'est vrai mon grand
père il est mort à l'âge de 46 ans elle
a eu ses enfants avec les femmes et on
se balade et il est mort et le boulot de
mon bon mon grand père salah sommes un
peu à mon boulot de jouer parce qu' il
avait quatre ou cinq taureaux et les
gens ils aiment les des vaches pour la
montera donc mais qui vient tout à
l'heure on en parle avec elle il a été
tué et les détails il a effectué par un
saut parce qu'il ya eu un moment les
gens ils amenaient pas assez de vaches
sont heureux et donc j'ai trop ils
avaient le sang noir noir donc est il
allé pour la forcer les chaînes elle a
été un court mais directement d'accord à
9 ans vous aviez des érections par le
simple fait de donner la main comme ça
vous vous donner la main
[Applaudissements]
prêté mon grand complexe et j'avais bien
sûr j'avais des béninois même dans la
mer parce que l'automation ville de mer
je mettais des maillots de bain beaucoup
plus grand du normal et souvent j'avais
des complexes terrible parce que je
commençais fille bonjour j'avais des
sélections jeu mais j'étais dans l'eau
je lui parlais dans le jeu fédérer
on comprenait pas et c'est tout mais
comme ça chez nous construit sa place
[Applaudissements]
et comparez et ça qu'est ce qui est à
langer callebaut jegun la moule s'est
passé samedi avec une lampe de poche
timsit
alors donc j'étais de timides à l'époque
comme ça vous êtes géniaux comme ça
c'est ton départ voilà comment voulez
vous soyez prêtre bonne maman elle
voulait que vous soyez c'est comme on
appelle ça les les enfants quand on a 10
ans née à côté du prêt de la petite
fille mon chien je fais ça pendant 12
mai avec la robe comme ça c'est bien le
maillot la maison ma tête c'était
toujours un grand j'étais comme des
personnes à l'intérieur de moi même
c'était un truc bizarre est alors à
saison donc vous en prions de sélection
il lui disait 2 mai valait le villan de
9 à 16 ans vous ne pouvez plus vous
partez dans la marine marchande cdu
atterri dans le marché de marine
marchande posait pas de femmes sur les
bateaux damas un moment masturbation du
maton selon maturation pendant un an à
17 ans vous venez à paris d'un périscope
boîte frère votre frère à un restaurant
à paris
oui vous rencontrer je vais vite parce
que vous rencontrez une cliente qui vous
emmène dans une boîte échangiste et là
vous rencontrez que relayer les pontets
la galerie matin c'est le pape
chez terra dans nintendo moi c'était
comme un conte près des mureaux
aujourd'hui mais merde c'est un peu ça
dans l'histoire parce que je voyais seb
ou 15 mai masturber dans ses bouquins au
moins dix ans avant oui et la journée
c'est presque effectivement je
connaissais toutes les filles qui avait
travaillé avec beaucoup défi platine
étaient beaucoup de sorties à la casse
je vis quelque chose pour moi c'était
vraiment quelque chose d'exceptionnel là
vous découvrez que des gens qui sont
payés pour faire l'amour quoique
finalement c'est ça peut être un boulot
vraiment un boulot et alors vous
commencez à prêt à faire votre trou dans
le milieu
[Applaudissements]
la ville de mons a bien cru qui est la
différence avec ruquier c'est que moi je
quelques bancs d'essais le matin bleu
express a surtout bien sûr donc hélas
vous avez un problème vous avez - vous
marrez là là vous avez un problème parce
que vous tombez amoureux d'une fille qui
s'appelle tina et elle veut que vous
arrêtiez le métier et ma vie moi auto
métier moi je dis bon d'accord c'est toi
j'étais amoureuse
vraiment c'était dur pour vous avez
mangé des moments j'avais même a rien à
manger
je pensais beaucoup de moi sans rien si
vous unissent en riant vis à vis envers
un monde d'amour et de beaucoup de
féliciter avec donc après vous avez
quitté tina êtes revenu dans dans le
métier vous êtes devenu la star c'est le
mal et c'est ce qui m'a laissée à la fin
parce que l'on pouvait plus parce que de
toute façon j'ai pas tellement je ne
vais pas en faisant l'amour tout le
temps helm a regretté le fait qu'elle
estime annick n 2 dé mieux qu'elle avait
un tout petit sexe très fermé très beau
très comme heroes après trois ans avec
moi
[Applaudissements]
les dangers
non
vous les posez des questions sous la
manche les 14 jeux joués samedi que moi
je ne doute pas c'est vachement bien de
dire ça va la vie humblement de ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé et ce qui
se trouve bien que nous explique samoa
on aurait tous voulu s établit à temps
on va faire un polaroïd de tech aux
pénaltys yeux quand j'aurai est démolie
avec mon énorme bazar conflit chirurgien
et redresse un truc normal si on n'a pas
une photo d'avant on va être là mais
ruban messieurs mesdames et messieurs
vraiment les meilleurs est arrivé ici
pour nous parler de son film
sectionnement le d'amour pour la goutte
de citron sur la shoah
quant à catherine jacob est morte de
rien vous savez ça vous ça vous choque
n'hésite pas à poser les questions et
suggestions ravis puisque est question
les réponses en même temps que vous
écoutez j'ai une belle vie je me suis
beaucoup amusé et j'ai vu des combats
mais cette étude
alors maintenant une question qu
siffredi bon vous réussissez beaucoup
parce que vous faites vous faites jamais
semble en fait sur vous quand vous
faites l'amour du vote secret en fait
moi votre succès c'est que vous ne
faites pas semblant qu'on drague on dit
voilà ce qu'est 6 under c5
il ya les glandeurs saxe est ce que vous
est-ce que vous parler italien à
l'oreille de vos partenaires il faut
américaines les adolescents
américaine et madame ont imaginé claque
allait en parler vous vous êtes en train
de faire l'amour avec une italienne n'a
à catherine jacob si vous faisiez
laquelle vous lui diriez quoi comme
phrase en italie en italie moullec qui
j'avais des enfants ce n'était rien
italien en italie l'apport quelques c4
bon de toute façon c'est l'histoire
américaine dirigeants mais plus je vous
le mets quand même complètement changé
aujourd'hui je suis pas docteur jeu
produit par les jeux haut de gamme
on passe à vos histoires de production
parce que l'âge et petites critiques à
vous faire des petits reproches à vous
faire oui aux coopératives à nous dire
alors est ce que votre sexe est assurée
j'essaie mais ils ne sont plus assurés
parce que la lloyd's pour pas perdre
leur réputation ils m'ont dit oui mais à
condition qu'on vient sur le sexe on
vous assure avant le toit avant le
tournage et il faut qu'on soit là mois
sans manger un peu ça parce qu'il soit
là
[Rires]
elysée idées aux filles à tf1 mais
toutes ne sont pas fous l'impuissance
normand pour la question il disait aussi
attention à ne pas lui est rayé le
casque c'est que je suis ça m'est arrivé
qui est filmé a mordu son élection alors
les problèmes comme deux petits
problèmes
de petites boulettes oui il ya eu sans
gain de boulaq il ya de petites
boulettes
il ya eu 110 que tu ne dis pas dit mais
pas bien vu les films à une suissesse de
belle famille qui vous a écrit pour
travailler avec vous la fait venir à
rome c'est un film que vous produisez et
voulait l'un des premiers oui et vous la
livrer quand même à 20 bonhomme quoi et
la fille salut à 20,20 type vava homme
s'est pas élargie ce lien peut tourner
la tête c'est bien qu'après quand il est
retourné à genève elle est un peu je
figurais pas faire un concours fait des
histoires mais deuxième affaire c'est si
denis alors là c'est donc voulu vous lui
faites l'amour dans les toilettes quoi
pour être les chiots dans les îles vous
tirez la chasse c'est le même film
c'est quand même pas très sympa non
c'est pas une question d'être pas sympa
c'est qu'ils soient par rapport à les
gens qui voient part des réelles et
connaissent pas la réalité c'est pas
sympa mais quand on parle
non mais je vous faisais c'est un des
gars si vous combien des questions
celles décédées questions très simples
pour le temps il faut que les gens
comprend bien ça qui est ça qui se passe
parce que sinon il peut penser alors que
les gars dans fois les deux attrapés la
tête lui mais dans les chiottes il tirer
sa révéré chasse - mais somme c'est les
films avec des gens qu'ils ont envie de
faire des fantasmes prêts et les femmes
non et les femmes et sont beaucoup plus
pervers que l'on parce que l'homme tu
veux mais d'où femme à côté et ils ce
sont les rois de la terre une femme ça
se passe tout de la tête et donc la
femme elle est beaucoup plus compliqué
de sa que les hommes y pense pour
exciter une femme il faut beaucoup plus
maintenant avec ça je veux pas dire
qu'il faut lui mettre un tel choc avec
un lien qui vous a répondu
il avait retiré
merci d'une infection
oui bien sûr le fantasme que vous n'avez
jamais réalisé qu'ils vous restent
aujourd'hui encore bien beaucoup pour
moi le fantasme est vrai c'est voir une
femme qui me regarde dans les yeux mais
des belges ou moins dans les yeux et
n'importe comment on le fait sans limite
donc sacem
c'est toujours mon fantasme courant
danoise elle vous êtes prévenus donc
voila vous rencontrez rocco siffredi
vous regarder dans les yeux là comme ça
vous lui dites ce qu'il vient de dire et
puisse aller voir alors on continue
en 1993 on est on arrive à vous
rencontrer là d'un coup ce qui est
formidable d'ailleurs dans cette
histoire c'est pour ça que ces cas là il
tombe sur une fille qui s'appelle rosa
il tournait un film avenue victor j mc
cain qui s'appelait bodyguard et en
cette fibre on vous la connaissez dans
un film mais les hongroises 1 et le
matin où vous tourner avec elle le fait
que vous fassiez l'amour avec d'autres
filles ça la fait pleurer à midi elle
sort elle sort du tournage en larmes et
donc vous êtes mariés en 96
vous avez vous avez un enfant mais
j'attends le deuxième on va on va
regarder on va vous allez voir rocco
siffredi très différent de tout ce que
vous pouvez imaginer
voilà ce que rosa est arrivé à faire
bravo rose à ce que rosa est arrivé à
faire de rocco siffredi et serge j'ai
essayé le shsh et quelqu'un parce que je
me suis dit si je cherche je me trouvais
mais en fait je trouve quelqu'un de très
belles et très très important c'est une
autre vie
ce maître monde quelqu'un c'est pas un
jeu de ma femme c'est tout couvert je
veux qu'il comptait sur tgv flammes et
chevaux je sais c'est qu'on peut
augmenter mais je me dis c'est un petit
singe second single écoute
oui mais moi je passais pour gérer notre
chez moi vraiment de malaxer un peu avec
ma femme ans et elle est très familier
la rue de lompret
on n'est pas fatigués physiquement
plutôt un coup psychologique au mans et
en même temps la fatigue
chaque fois que je suis allée liane
s'assemble parce que psychologiquement
je suis pas s'allier vous rien aux
amazones ont changé d'avis parce qu'il
m'a donné beaucoup de choses qui avant
je me suis je rêvais sûrement d'avoir et
j'ai jamais eu
et en fait je me suis jamais toujours
dit jamais je me joins ma femme c'est ça
mon amour c'est dans ma tête c'est dans
mon cas c'est tout en live sur le matin
je pense à elles et je rappelle tout le
temps elle m'appelle donc ma femme c'est
mon amour je veux absolument l'occupé de
mon album est vraiment absolument
absolument absolument je veux lui faire
tous les choses qu'ils ne préfèrent le
fais mais je passerai ma foi je suis un
rose a beau touche à la fin du chantier
de faire jouer travaille jamais ne
sommes absolument pas il faut qu on
partage le bébé les deux bouts
magnéto gonflable qui va l'amener à la
mer pendant 10 tours de magie
la somme tous mes rêves
[Musique]
je pense
[Applaudissements]
les arrivées apprivoiser rocco siffredi
et les forces est rosa alors dites moi
vous trouvez pas qu'il est formidable
avec son bébé la ville est géniale idée
géniale tout le temps là les balles il
dit simplement les choses s'étaient
s'éteint c'est un homme qui est très
respectable en tout cas toute mon amitié
[Applaudissements]
il est resté frais parce qu'il pourrait
y en avoir marre quoi au bout d'un
moment je me trouvais vous trouvez fait
vous ne trouvez nature c'est le
contraire vous et c'est une émission
finalement qui tourne très fille lola le
porno et le vix à la politique parce que
ségolène royal il ya peu de temps vous
le savez thierry a déclaré qu'il fallait
supprimer le film porno sur canal+ parce
que c'était dangereux pour les enfants
qui pouvaient tomber par hasard là
dessus alors moi je dis aux parents qui
ont des enfants qui par hasard pourrait
tomber sur un film porno que c'est pas
très grave si vos enfants tombent sur
des images de films porno on n'avait
qu'à leur dire c'est pas grave c'est de
la politique le monsieur et madame ils
sont en train de négocier un contrat
pour elf
[Applaudissements]